I come from the gutter and I'm not a
compromiser world favorite Steve
McClaren groovy thanks you love cars
liquor women and he was interesting and
cool and dangerous
leave her scratch marks on the history
of filmmaking I'm a driver I'm an actor
and a filmmaker I just want to get down
this is the guts what was made when we
were shooting this room
should happen to know man you gotta
believe in what you're doing by doing
what I do
use quasi directed he made his own
didn't have to answer to anybody
you betrayed me stabbed me in the back
I'll never talk to you again everything
was pushed to the extreme
they wanted to shoot a motor racing
picture because we've been something
close to my heart
and I don't think there's any race
driver that can really tell you why he
races but I think he probably should
what's the most seminal moment in his
life I did that something that he
started
we wanted to finish it as far as the
reality of some concern that's where
it's at
that's where it should be Lamar is the
turning point in his life
it meant a lot to him
almost everything
miss dr. John Wayne too can get out as a
mouthful buyer